zuerst in taxham vom papier sei mit
youtube channel und wie haben die frage
da ich entweder gerade
euer video gesehen auf youtube illegale
fans und jetzt ist unsere fragen euch
weil er tat sind noch sagt so tief wie
das ist nicht immer verfügbar ob ihr
dann auch selber öfters auf youtube
unterwegs seid text lässt darauf
vermuten ja ohne dass unsere frage genau
wen findet ihr sowohl auf youtube wenn
ihr auf youtube aktiv seid und habe die
erst machte doch habt ihr account wo ihr
andere leute abonniert oder sowas oder
hated man ja oder auch dieses tier kanal
wenn ihr
bereit seid ja
wir werden
also liebe simon liebe simon und liebes
tanzbär ich hab mich jetzt eben gefragt
wer ist wer bei euch im video zwar nicht
so leicht zu ich kann nämlich nicht ich
hab natürlich einen eigenen account und
noch zwei andere accounts mit dem ich
immer also wie justin bieber kommentare
los lasst und reinstädtler in den dreck
ziehen und ja wir haben natürlich aber
wir haben wie er vielleicht schon
gemerkt hat machen wir wenn ihr über
facebook was schreibt oder auch gleich
den ttv beschreibt wir nutzen das auch
privat also da wird eigentlich jede
frage immer beantwortet und so weil wir
sind sozusagen
penner ohne grenzen und wir sind auch
zum anfassen